on est à londres
aujourd'hui on va se tester ce que ce
cas ce que la 2a kg je vous ai déjà
testé le n500 ça c'est le y 500 je vous
le maniez parce que j'ai un rendez vous
c'est youtube londres dans ou dans 35
minutes je vous montre rapidement ses
quatre ailleurs de la boîte aux filons
seul test et puis ils vont dire est ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire c'est
ça la mode
alors ils ont fait des couleurs sympa
qui a caché le même code sur le soin
casque alors gardez toujours assez
sommaire vous ouvrez alors normalement
il ya le casque à l'intérieur vous
enlever ça en dessous prendre une petite
pochette pour l'emmener partout avec soi
on est ici du poil recharger en micro
usb usb
on a ici du jack jack pour le brancher
et on a une petite notice comme je vous
le disais la petite pochette pour
déranger le casque est bien évidemment
on a le casque en lui-même avec ses
connectiques mais s'en va détailler tout
à l'heure
[Musique]
bon et hugo parce que je suis prêt moi
pourquoi est ce que je suis toujours
[Musique]
mon premier rendez vous de la matinée
jusqu'au bout là bas la direction
youtube
[Musique]
bon voilà ça c'est fait rendez vous chez
youtube assez intéressant maintenant je
me soucie des scénarios en trois heures
tapas tout loupé ce que je vous propose
c'est que je file à l'aéroport je me
poste je fais tous les contrôles je fais
contrôler leurs valises et ensuite on
prend du temps ensemble pour discuter de
ce casque est vous dire comment et si
vaut le coup oui quoi comment combien
écoute ça tout ça tout ça quoi go
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous parlais de 7 et casques la
cheville de l'aéroport c'est qu'il y
avait de monde sait ici si vous insultez
pas un truc si vous faites pas du
shopping c'est que vous n'êtes plus fort
que tout le monde parce que c'est
strictement impossible donc on va se
trouver un petit peu un peu tranquille
pour aller discuter tout ça voyez petit
casque sympa je vais vous expliquer le
confort le son la qualité le rapport
qualité prix très important et si c'est
un peu compliqué attend de la cua huit
minutes de marge temps minutes de marche
je pense qu'on va se trouver un coin
l'abri on sera pas mal
la première chose je vais vous parler du
design je peux aussi vous êtes coutumier
des casques si vous en utilisez oui non
quoi souvent ou pas du tout le design
est pas là john deere déjà je trouve
kaka j'ai enfin un excellent choix au
niveau de ses couleurs la coloris très
sympa très moderne dans la graine à
plusieurs il ya du rose ya du noir il ya
pas mal de différentes couleurs trouve
que ça pour moi c'est vraiment un
excellent compromis donc d'un point de
vue purement esthétique il est bien vous
avez une petite mousse à mémoire de
forme qui est hyper hyper cool qui est
petites finitions de couleur à
l'intérieur je trouve vraiment sa part
car assez facilement le droit c'est le
gauche c'est écrit c'est écrit là côté
bouton vous avez ici un petit bouton de
volume pour le laisser pour le monter
'place top ici votre prise directe pour
le rebrancher en filaire si vous avez
besoin de l'autre côté un bouton pour la
lui mais aussi pour venir l'appareil est
tout simplement il suffit de glisser
c'est hyper facile et là vous avez un
petit bouton pour le côté son ambiance
ça c'est assez bizarre que kg nous ait
fait ça c'est de la recharge en micro
usb
alors que l'usb c'est déferle de partout
et ce qu'ils ont fait pour des raisons
qu est-ce qu au final le micro usb et
moins cher que l'usb c'est qu'elle ça y
est peut-être une raison de ce côté là
donc
bon déjà d'un point de vue purement
design c'est bien c'est brand et à
cacher sur le dessus vous avez le nom du
modèle sais pas si vous voyez qui est
noté ici y série ce qui est écrit là
donc voila mon point de vue purement
esthétique design c'est bien tout le
régler à votre tête
alors maintenant tous que je lui
reprochais c'est
la tenue parce que en fait pour vous
profiter vraiment dû bonne expérience
sonore il faut qu'ils soient hyper bien
positionné bien en face de vos oreilles
faut bien trouver votre position alors
l'opposition at on pas tout de suite il
perd naturellement il faut le poser mais
je vous dis bien positionner au bon
endroit
bon sang ça se trouve assez facilement
par an du touquet est un peu chiante ces
casses c'est que des gogos bouger que
m'a tout de suite voyez il bouge donc
c'est pas du tout un casse qui est fait
pour le running vous n'allez pas les
courir avec ou alors si vous allez
courir c'est que vous avez mis du scotch
chatterton partout autour de votre tête
sinon c'est strictement impossible pour
ça c'est le truc que j'avais un petit
peu à les regretter sur ce casque là
c'est que vous prenez vous le posez vos
bouger n'est pas de mouvements de tête
pas de mouvements brusques
omettant le confort en lui-même je suis
pas hyper hyper hyper fan de notre côté
parce que j'habite eu au casque à très
haut de gamme w h mix m3 j'en ai quand
même 200 euros puisque ce produit donc
le confond avec le même folie en galère
un petit peu pour trouver la bonne
position sur ses oreilles simple à côté
de ça vous êtes sur un quinze qui coûte
149 euros donc voilà on a pas trop trop
lui en vouloir non plus on n'a pas trop
lui en demander
il fait le job une fois vous êtes trio
de position qu'il est bien positionné
vous avez bien placé avec la musique
moment de rendre compte s'il est bien
positionné par rapport aux conduits
auditifs leçon lui-même est plutôt bien
chez vous détailler dans quelques
instants vous avez un autre truc dessus
c'est détection mouvement dire que
lorsque vous l'avez mis vous écoutez de
la musique lorsque vous emmenez votre
casque il va reconnaître qu' un
mouvement et à ce moment là la musique
va couper c'est pas toujours très très
bon ça marche pas hyper hyper bien parce
que des fois ça va pas couper et en plus
en vous et votre casque autour du cou
que la musique est coupée et bien à ce
moment là des fois la musique repas ces
mots et de la musique d'emploi sais pas
d'où ça vient en fait 5 ans doit donc la
détection de mouvements pour moi ça
c'est pas un truc qui est complètement
hyper hyper optimisé par contre côté
isolation facile parce que là dessus
vous n'avez pas une réduction bruit
active ça ça vient ponctuer les oreilles
et pour le coup ça les obstrue bien donc
c'est là quand même vous isoler un peu
de l'extérieur donc lorsque vous êtes en
du transport en commun soit un métro ou
un bus en train un avion sa vie un petit
peu vous couper ça sera pas aussi
efficace qu'un casque à réduction brute
qui coûtera 200 euros de plus mais ça
fait pas beaucoup de vols
après très clairement sur ce produit là
on est sur un positionnement milieu de
gamme on n'est pas sur un casque haut de
gamme comme julie est quand même une
différence de tarif qui est assez
significatif si vous allez sur un
produit haut de gamme il faut vraiment
ajouter 200 euros on est sur un
positionnement médias vous allez bien
évidemment une fonctionnalité kit main
libre vous pouvez passer des coups de
fil avec alors ça marche c'est pas un
truc de fou de toute façon que ce soit
même des casques coûte beaucoup plus
cher ou ceux typologie de casques là
c'est pas là vous allez voir le meilleur
show pour pouvoir communiquer avec
quelqu'un et c'est pas là où la personne
aussi le mieux vous entende si
l'environnement est trop bruyant vous
allez boire plusieurs micro pour la
réduction du bruit environnant
c'est quand même pas complètement mais
j'ai douze points de vue là je ne
recommanderais pas pour passer des coups
de fil occasionnellement pour dépanner
mais guère mieux côté purement technique
vous avez du bluetooth 4.2 dans ce cas
ce que vous n'avez pas d'app été x vous
est pas non plus d'applications dédiées
pour digérer ça par exemple vous l'avez
sur le n700 vous avez une application
permettra de générer pas mal de trucs là
dessus non vous avez votre casque le son
est comme ça on peut toujours utiliser
vos applications de musique pour venir
régler les coalisés heures mais du point
de vue purement en construction en tout
cas acquise et il n'ya pas d'appli dédié
donc ça il faut le savoir
après de notre côté est-ce que vous avez
réellement besoin sur un casque qui est
dans cette gamme de prix
je suis patient il ya un mode qui existe
qui s'appelle le mode ambiante voyage
vous allez montrer tout à l'heure vous
avez le bouton pour l'activer alors le
mode ambiante au maire et vous permet de
faire quoi en gros il va réduire le son
de votre casque le volume sonore de
votre casque pour vous permettre de
mieux vous rend compte du son
environnement cusson qui a autour de
vous bon l'idée est plutôt bonne c'est
en gros lorsque vous êtes à l'extérieur
vous pouvez soit entendre ce cas autour
de vous pour éviter vous faire écraser
par une voiture typiquement fait
relativement pas mal ça peut vous
permettre aussi lorsque vous parlez à
quelqu'un de pouvoir entendre la
conversation mais dans l'absolu c'est
pas terrible pour deux raisons la toute
première raison c'est que le volume
sonore est quand même relativement
baissé et la qualité elle est vraiment
pas terrible terrible on sait déjà de ce
point de vue là écouter de la musique
avec un son qui est pas terrible et qui
est trop bas ça strictement rien et en
plus ce que vous aller capter
l'extérieur c'est pas précis s'est pas
gêné pour moi la qualité là dessus non
plus n'est pas au rendez vous maintenant
qu'on est il de la qualité audio passe
95 que c'est quand même relativement
bien le fait que
on sent confortable ou non c'est
intéressant mais le truc le plus
important ça reste quand même la qualité
du son alors est ce que le son est bien
oui non bien restituée oui non c'est un
poids qui était intéressant alors je
sais que j'ai des restaurants sont pas
forcément hyper bonne vue que équipé
d'un casque un peu au top c'est toujours
compliqué quand on écoute des casques en
moins bonne qualité
néanmoins je trouve que le rendu sonore
est vraiment vraiment vous n'allez pas
voir autant doux ronronnement dans de
graves erreurs des aiguilles aussi
précis que sur gasquet très haut de
gamme qui va forcément beaucoup plus
cher mais moi le rendu est super super
honnête on a des 100 médium qui son
corps avec des graves qui sont présents
mais pas trop on a des aigus qui sont à
ses fins le sont d'assez bonne qualité
je vous dis vous pouvez venir régler
après avec les équaliseur d'autres
applications audio
ça peut corriger un petit peu ça peut le
type est en tout cas légèrement mais
dans l'absolu comme ça d'un point de vue
purement plat le spectre est vraiment
intéressant il ya un beau boulot qui
était fait par un kg
on connaît sais pas si vous connaissez
mais en tout cas c'est une vraie
expertise à kg s'est fondée casques
depuis des années moi j'ai connu à kg
c'était en 2001 2002 2003 2004 lorsque
j'étais assistant studio
l'enregistrement on avait des casques
pour l'enregistrement justement kg et
j'adorais la couleur audio c'est vrai
que vous avez un son qui ont un peu
cheap et a légèrement plus typé que ce
qu'on a retrouvé sur un casque sony qui
sera beaucoup plus polyvalent
alors beaucoup moins typé sur ce produit
là que sur le 1 700 néanmoins la couleur
est un homme relativement bien pour moi
la qualité audio est au rendez vous donc
si vous voulez un casque qui est une
bonne qualité audio qui est bien il a
tenu à l'est pas complètement froid au
niveau
au niveau de la tête les un bon rapport
qualité prix je trouve que celui là il
est vraiment intéressant puis surtout vu
le positionnement tarifaire 149 euros
pour moi il ya rien à dire là-dessus
dernier point qui est important et non
des moindres c'est la question de
l'autonomie vous avez une batterie de
900 millions père heures à kg nous donne
une autonomie allant jusqu'à 33 heures
d'écouté et dans l'absolu mais c'est
vrai que je suis pas déçu je trouve que
l'autonomie nous toute façon les casques
comme ça lorsque vous allez partir en
déplacement même s'ils sont pas chargés
à fond ça consomme relativement peu
celui là ne déroge pas à la règle
les 33 heures alors je n'ai pas calculé
à la minute près mis à l'heure près mais
de mon point de vue en tout cas on est
dans les chiffres donnés par à gaz et
donc c'est pareil
l'autonomie là-dessus vraiment bien on a
un casque qui en termes de qualité audio
on va recycler dans le prix ont vraiment
rester dans cette idée là parce que si
on part sont des références et de
casques à plumes 358 son frère un peu
mais pour un tarif à 149 euros
l'audio et de qualité l'autonomie et la
tasse et un couac il vraiment forte le
design est sympa il obstrue suffisamment
bien les oreilles pour le coup pas un
peu du monde extérieur
le côté appels téléphoniques c'est good
the fuck le côté son ambiance c'est pas
terrible terrible le côté tenu sur la
tête lorsque vous allez bouger c'est une
catastrophe
mais au-delà de ces points là si vous
voulez un casque qui soit quand même
relativement polyvalent discret légers
et faciles à transporter dans sa petite
rousse qui coûtent pas hyper cher et
avec une belle qualité audio pour moi le
hac âgées y 500 peut être vraiment une
bonne solution
bon voilà c'est pour ces informations
concernant ce casque de à kg et dites
moi ce que vous en pensez j'ai mon avion
dans mon petit tu as donc je vais
embarquer je me prépare en tout cas en
barque et je vais te dire ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous le
trouve intéressant oui non pas comment
par rapport à la concurrence par rapport
à ce que vous avez est ce que vous
l'avez est ce que vous pourriez la boire
est ce qui vous intéresse toussa toussa
toussa toussa voilà s'embrasser au
rendez vous dès demain
et maintenant à moi de m'envoyer en
l'air un matin